* Herzschläge *
Ich denke gerne viel,
aber bei solchen Sachen denke ich:
"Lass es auf dich zukommen."
Normale Typen haben mich
eigentlich nie interessiert.
Alle Paare haben Differenzen, ob
man nun aus dem gleichen Land kommt
oder um die ganze Welt reisen muss.
* Herzschläge *
* Romantische Melodie *
# Take my hand, take me anywhere,
as long as you are there.
# Take my hand.
# Together we will be
forever you and me.
* Herzschläge *
* Möwenkreischen *
(Bei Katja und AJ in Neuseeland
sieht das Leben auf den ersten Blick
immer ein bisschen wie Ferien aus.)
(Zumindest wenn man
aus der Schweiz kommt
und sich das Meer vor der Haustür
nicht gewohnt ist.)
Are you alright?
(Aber heute ist wirklich
ein entspannter Tag für die beiden.)
(Die Bankfachfrau aus dem Thurgau
und der Surfartikelhändler
mit Maori-Wurzeln
geniessen einen freien Tag -
Tochter Narja ist bei Verwandten.)
Kommt es oft vor,
dass ihr Tage für euch allein habt?
Nicht sehr oft.
Ohne Narja eigentlich nie.
Never?
- No.
Wir haben keine Verwandten,
wo wir wohnen,
so ist sie immer mit uns zusammen.
Es wäre natürlich schön,
wenn ab und zu Grosseltern da wären,
die sie hüten könnten.
* Lockere Gitarrenklänge *
Wenn man mit einer Frau vom
anderen Ende der Welt zusammen ist,
gibt es Pro und Kontra.
Die Vorteile:
Man kann in die Schweiz gehen
und Fondue und Raclette essen.
Der Nachteil:
Man muss 24 Std. fliegen,
um überhaupt dorthin zu kommen.
Nein, ernsthaft,
es ist sicher schwieriger.
Aber wenn man jemanden liebt,
findet man immer Lösungen.
Auch wenn es mal
Schwierigkeiten gab,
wir sind immer noch hier
und es klappt mit uns.
Wir bleiben dran.
Do you see him already?
- Here we go! A snapper.
(Onkel Greg,
der für AJ ein Ersatzvater ist,
hat zum Fischen eingeladen.)
How big is it?
Oh, it'll be 40 cm.
Geht das immer so schnell?
Oh, nein!
Wir waren auch schon fischen
und haben gar nichts gefangen.
Deshalb finde ich Fischen
gar nicht so toll.
Ach so! Ich dachte,
du seist völlig begeistert.
Ich fange jeden Abend
mein Nachtessen ... Nein!
Hungry little snapper.
- It was hungry, wasn't it?
Was machen eigentlich
die Frauen in Neuseeland?
Männer surfen, wenn es geht,
und sonst gehen sie fischen.
Und die Frauen?
Ich habe schon das Gefühl,
dass die Rollenverteilung
hier noch traditioneller ist.
Viele in meinem Freundeskreis
sind wirklich Mütter,
die zu Hause bleiben.
Also bist du wirklich ein Exot,
nicht nur weil du Schweizerin bist,
sondern weil ihr ein
komplett anderes Rollenmodell lebt.
Ja, vielleicht schon etwas.
In der Schweiz kommt es
auch noch nicht so häufig vor,
dass der Mann zu Hause ist.
AJ war ja fast ein Jahr lang
der Stay-at-home-dad.
Gibt es Kommentare von deinen
Freunden oder auch von seinen?
Ehrlich gesagt
gab es mehr Kommentare
von einigen meiner
Schweizer Freunde.
Die fanden eher noch:
"Was macht er denn?"
"Hat er bereits wieder einen Job?"
Als er kündigte und zu Hause war,
fragten alle:
"Hat er schon wieder einen Job?
Was macht er nachher?"
In Neuseeland ist es anders
als in der Schweiz.
Sie leben mehr im Jetzt
als im Morgen und Übermorgen.
Ja.
Ich denke,
ich werde nie genau gleich werden.
Das wird man nie, wenn man nicht
aus dem Land stammt, egal woher.
Die Schweiz ist mein Zuhause,
auch wenn ich hier lebe.
Ich sehe mich nicht
als Neuseeländerin,
ich bin immer noch voll Schweizerin.
Solltest auch du mal gerne fischen,
sprechen wir noch mal darüber!
Genau.
What?
Oh!
- Oh, ein Hai!
Do you keep it
or do you let it go?
Is it slimy?
- No, no.
Wow!
Okay, bye-bye!
- Bye, baby shark!
He can come back
and eat these other fish.
Könntest du in einem Land wie der
Schweiz leben, weit weg vom Meer?
Eine schwierige Vorstellung,
so für immer.
What are you looking over at me?
Mit einem Seitenblick zu dir!
Das diskutieren wir gerade.
Vielleicht nicht für immer,
aber für eine gewisse Zeit.
Für eine Weile ginge das schon.
Ich war in der Schweiz,
es ist schön da.
Aber für immer?
Das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen.
(Und dann fischt sie
eben doch noch - Katja.)
(Es braucht Kompromisse, wenn
sich zwei so lieben wie Katja und AJ,
aber aus verschiedenen Welten
kommen.)
(Dass sie für immer
zusammensein wollen, wissen sie.)
(Aber ob in Neuseeland
oder in der Schweiz -
diese Frage wird sie wohl
ein Leben lang begleiten.)
# Take my hand.
(Für mich ist es Zeit, Adieu zu sagen
und zu danken für diesen Einblick
in das Leben
auf der anderen Seite der Welt.)
# Together we will be
forever you and me.
Ob ich realisiert habe,
dass es Konsequenzen hat?
Eigentlich schon, einen Moment lang.
Ich dachte schon: "That's it now?"
"Ist es wirklich das,
was ich immer gewollt habe,
was ich mein ganzes Leben lang
gesucht habe,
von dem ich immer gespürt habe,
dass es so sein muss?"
"Wie kommen die Mädchen damit klar?"
Ja.
Am schwierigsten
war es für sie selber.
Sie gab die Familie und alles auf.
Es beeindruckte mich,
dass sie mich offensichtlich so sehr
liebte, dass sie das in Kauf nahm.
* Entspannte Gitarrenmusik *
(Die Freiheit
in der Prärie von Montana
hat für Brigitte einen Preis.)
(Und der ist nicht gering.)
* Schwungvolle Musik *
Wenn die Tage im Flathead-Reservat
kürzer werden
und die Zeit für Motorradreparaturen
und zum Nachdenken wieder länger,
dann tauchen auch
Fragen zur Zukunft auf.)
Jetzt müssen wir schauen,
dass es gerade aufliegt.
Es nachher wieder abzumachen,
ist hart.
(Gedanken über die eigene Zukunft
und die
ihrer Töchter Dewii und Adina,
die Brigitte
in der Schweiz zurückgelassen hat.)
Plötzlich kam er mit dieser Idee.
Er sagte: "Weisst du, deine Kinder
werden irgendwann mal Mütter sein."
"Du wirst Grossmutter werden, also
müsstest du in der Schweiz sein."
Ich frage ihn: "Würdest du dich
in der Schweiz denn wohlfühlen?"
"Würde dir das passen?"
Und dann sagte er:
"Ich bin dort happy und zu Hause,
wo du bist."
(Als Brigitte die Schweiz
vor acht Jahren verlassen hatte,
waren ihre Töchter
18 und 20 Jahre alt.)
* Ruhige Gitarrenmusik *
(Jay)
Hey!
Du siehst gut aus.
Wie geht es dir? Alles in Ordnung?
Ja.
Ja, und Dewii?
Sie isst gerade.
Wir wollen sie trotzdem sehen,
das ist egal.
There she is.
- Hoi. - Hi.
Guten Appetit.
(Brigitte versucht, einmal pro Woche
mit ihren Töchtern Kontakt zu haben.)
(Zum letzten Mal gesehen hat sie
Adina und Dewii vor gut zwei Jahren.)
Passt auf euch auf!
Ich vermisse euch.
Love you, guys! Tschüss.
I miss them.
Es gab Leute, die fanden,
ich lasse meine Kinder im Stich.
Aber sie waren schon 18 Jahre alt.
Sie waren zwar in der Lehre,
aber ich finde ...
Hier gehen die Kinder ins College,
sie ziehen zu Hause aus
in diesem Alter.
Wir haben ja darüber geredet. Ich
habe sie nicht im Stich gelassen.
Wir haben das mit ihnen besprochen.
Für sie ist es auch gut, wenn ich
glücklich bin. Für uns stimmt es.
Aber es war natürlich
für alle nicht einfach.
* Ruhige Klänge *
Ich wollte nie sagen,
dass ich Schweizer bin,
denn ich habe das Gefühl,
im Ausland wird das
schnell falsch interpretiert.
"Du bist Schweizer?
Du bist Millionär."
"Nein, ich bin bloss Schweizer,
es dauert noch etwas,
bis ich Millionär bin."
Also habe ich einen Italiener
gespielt, das kommt immer gut an.
Ich sagte ihr:
"Io sono italiano. Komm her!"
Si.
* Schwungvolle mexikanische Musik *
(Nancy und Demis sind heute 31
und seit vier Jahren verheiratet.)
(Sie leben dort,
wo es für sie gerade zu tun gibt.)
(Im Moment sind sie
in Monterrey in Mexiko.)
(Dort, wo Nancy aufgewachsen ist.)
(Nancy hat in Mexiko
Psychologie studiert,
Demis hat in Zürich eine Banklehre
und die Berufsmatura gemacht.)
(Bis die beiden ein Paar wurden,
waren einige Etappen nötig.)
(Heute zeigen uns
Demis und Nancy einen Ort,
der für Mexiko typisch ist.)
(Arm und Reich trifft sich
am Sonntag auf dem Markt.)
Jeden Sonntag wird hier gespielt.
Man hört sie am anderen Ende rufen.
Man denkt, es sei ein Fussballspiel,
aber es ist nur Bingo.
* Rufe auf Spanisch *
Es geht nicht ums grosse Geld.
Sie spielen, damit sie
zu Hause genug zu essen haben.
Sie bekommen z.B. Milch, Cola, Reis.
Teigwaren, Putzmittel.
Alles Dinge,
die man zu Hause braucht.
Vielleicht gewinnen wir WC-Papier,
das ist immer gut.
(Vor neun Jahren
hat Demis sein Bankerleben
samt Anzug und Krawatte
abgestreift,
hat sich von seinen Eltern,
die gerade in der Trennung waren,
verabschiedet und ist aufgebrochen,
um die Welt zu entdecken.)
Ich war damals noch unterwegs,
meine erste Weltreise,
nachdem ich die Berufsmatura
abgeschlossen hatte.
Ich war schon
eineinhalb Jahre unterwegs,
als ich auf sie gestossen bin,
in Puerto Vallarta,
eher im Süden Mexikos
an der pazifischen Küste.
Ich sah sie in einem Club
beim Tanzen.
Ich stand draussen ...
... und verliebte mich
gleich visuell.
Ich nahm sie bei der Hand
und zog sie zu mir.
Nach ein paar Minuten
ging sie wieder weg.
Das Spiel ist schon vorbei
und ich habe es nicht gemerkt.
Ich habe Glück in der Liebe!
Was will ich mehr?
Oh!
- "Oh!"
(Demis musste um die Liebe kämpfen.)
(Nancy wollte erst
gar nichts von ihm wissen.)
(Er konnte nur
ihre Telefonnummer erobern.)
* Fröhliche Musik *
Sie hat mir
eine so extreme Abfuhr erteilt,
dass es meinem Ego so geschadet hat,
dass ich es nicht
auf mir sitzen lassen konnte.
Nach einem Tag
ging sie zurück nach Monterrey,
das 25 Busstunden
von hier entfernt ist.
Ich bin ihr einfach
nach Monterrey gefolgt.
25-26 Std. mit dem Bus.
Ich habe ihr geschrieben:
"Hey, rate mal, wo ich bin!"
"Ja, wo bist du jetzt wieder?"
"Ich bin hier in Monterrey."
Und sie so: "Was?"
"Mein Gott, das ist ein Psychopath,
der will mich vergewaltigen."
"Das ist ein mega schlimmer Typ."
No? Pensabas que soy un maniaco?
- Si.
(Aber dank seinem Charme öffnen sich
Haustür und kurz danach auch Herzen
von Nancy
und der ganzen Familie Cortez.)
(Das ist achteinhalb Jahre her.)
(Und jetzt besuche ich Demis
und Nancy im Haus ihrer Eltern.)
825?
Hat es denn hier irgendwo Nummern?
Ah! Okay.
* Bellen *
Hola!
- Hola!
La madre de Nancy?
- Nancy.
Ah! Soy Mona.
Hermosa?
- Tu.
Oh! Muchas gracias.
Tu nombre?
Rosi.
- Rosi? Also. Mona.
* Rosi spricht spanisch. *
Vielen Dank!
Ciao!
- Hoi. Ich bin Mona.
Freut mich, Demis. Ich habe
nasse Haare, habe gerade geduscht.
Kein Problem.
Man wird gleich geherzt und umarmt.
Das ist Mambino? Hoi!
Hallo!
- Hola, Mona.
Freut mich sehr.
How are you? Good?
(All die Menschen
treffe ich heute zum ersten Mal.)
(Aber schon nach 5 Min. wurde ich
in Mexiko mehr umarmt und geküsst
als in der Schweiz
in einer ganzen Woche.)
Für mich ist das
der erste Mexiko-Besuch.
Kannst du ihnen sagen:
Ich möchte gerne noch mehr sehen,
wie man in Mexiko lebt.
* Sie sprechen spanisch. *
Die Liebe der Leute,
dass du die siehst.
Das wirst du gleich merken,
wenn du aus dieser Tür gehst.
(Und noch etwas erfahre ich bald:
dass man hier ganz offen umgeht
mit den Gefühlen - den schönen,
aber auch mit den schweren.)
Kennst du Enchiladas?
Das sind rote Tortillas.
Darauf kommt ...
- ... Chili.
Das ist Chili.
- Okay. Muy picante?
No picante.
- No picante?
Nein, es ist eher eine Tomatensauce.
- Das ist nicht so scharf.
Scharf ist es dann auf dem Markt,
wenn wir probieren gehen.
Ist das für Schweizer?
- Ja, sie hat Rücksicht genommen.
Auf welchem Schärfe-Niveau bist du?
Ich bin schon auf einem
sehr hohen Schärfe-Niveau.
Ich bin jetzt
in einem mexikanischen Prozess.
Als sie dich zum ersten Mal gesehen
hat, was dachte sie, ganz ehrlich?
* Demis spricht spanisch. *
Zuerst ist mir aufgefallen,
dass er anders ist.
Ich habe sofort gewusst, dass er
der Ehemann meiner Tochter wird.
Warum?
Er hat mich entzückt, verzaubert.
Ich liebe ihn wie einen Sohn.
* Sie sprechen spanisch. *
Ich empfinde sie auch als Mutter.
Ich dachte, das sei unmöglich,
die Schwiegermutter so zu lieben
wie die eigene Mutter.
(Dass die Verbundenheit so tief ist,
hat vielleicht noch einen
anderen Grund - einen traurigen.)
(Als Demis vor fünf Jahren zum
zweiten Mal zu Nancy nach Mexiko kam,
war Familie Cortez tief erschüttert.)
(Eric, Nancys 19-jähriger Bruder,
hatte sich kurz davor
das Leben genommen.)
Es gab eine 180°-Wende.
Die Situation war ziemlich planlos.
Man hatte zuerst keine Lebenslust.
Wir wussten nicht,
wofür wir noch leben sollten.
Aber wir wissen,
dass er hier präsent ist,
und wir wissen, dass wir irgendwann
alle zusammenkommen werden.
* Melancholische Flötenmusik *
* Schluchzen *
Sie sagte vorhin, es wäre schön,
wenn er jetzt auch hier wäre.
Es ist gerade
während dieser Festtage passiert.
Im Monat November.
Es ist schön, dass du hier bist,
dass ihr hier seid,
denn das ist eine Ablenkung für uns.
Das waren seine liebsten Festtage,
der Tag der Toten.
Das hat uns alle
in eine Depression gestürzt.
Zugleich weiss man:
Das Leben ist kurz.
Sie leben jeden Tag,
als ob es der letzte wäre.
Sie planen nicht: "So viel Geld
habe ich auf der Seite",
sondern sie geben es gleich aus.
Sie leben heute, weil morgen
vielleicht gar nicht mehr existiert.
* Melancholische Flötenmusik *
* Herzschläge *
* Er spricht französisch. *
Woran ich mich erinnere:
dass ich bei unserem ersten Treffen
viel gestresster
und verkrampfter war,
als ich es mir je vorgestellt hätte.
Und woran ich mich bei ihm
erinnern kann, als wir uns umarmten:
dass er einen Herzschlag
von ca. 10'000 hatte.
Ich konnte nicht glauben, dass
ein Herz so schnell schlagen kann.
Das ist mir aufgefallen:
wie schnell sein Herz schlägt.
Dass da also jemand
sehr, sehr aufgeregt ist.
* Liebliche Gitarrenmusik *
(Meteorologe Thomas Kleiber wusste,
worauf er sich einlässt,
wenn er zu David
und dessen Familie zieht:
auf den berüchtigten,
endlosen Winter von Quebec
und das Wohnen im Untergeschoss
im Haus der Schwiegereltern.)
* Summen *
So.
- On va allumer les lumieres un peu.
Oui.
- Ca.
On doit le bouger.
Okay.
I have two long underwears.
(Es erinnert ein wenig an die
Wohnsituation einer Teenager-Liebe,
so im Soussol des Elternhauses.)
Natürlich
ist es nicht meine Wohnung,
ich kann nicht das gleiche Chaos
machen wie zu Hause.
Ich habe zumindest das Gefühl,
ich sollte nicht.
Was vielleicht
auch nicht schlecht ist.
Aber ...
Es ist natürlich eine Umstellung.
Ich habe momentan
auch keinen festen Beruf,
muss meine Hobbys
hier neu definieren.
Das ist es, was mich einschränkt,
dass ich so ein wenig abhängig ...
Oder wie soll ich sagen?
Eine Zeit lang nicht mein ...
Ich muss mich wieder finden.
Das ist aber auch toll.
Man kann alte, blöde Dinge aufgeben
und neue anfangen.
Das ist es.
Aber die Wohnverhältnisse ...
Ich bin sehr anpassungsfähig.
Wäre Quebec nicht so kalt,
könnte man auch im Zelt wohnen.
Das ist jetzt mal
für ein paar Monate.
Dann sehen wir,
ob wir eine Wohnung suchen.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge, lachen *
Aber, wir sind nicht schwul.
(Wärme und sich wohlzufühlen
haben zum Glück nur bedingt
mit Aussentemperaturen zu tun.)
(Davids Familie hat Thomas
von Anfang an herzlich aufgenommen.)
(Und das, obwohl sie
den Schweizer kaum kannten,
als er ihren Sohn geheiratet hat.)
Thomas ist sehr unkompliziert.
Er ist ein grosszügiger
und äusserst angenehmer Mensch.
Die zwei
führen hier ihr eigenes Leben
und ich mische mich nicht ein.
Thomas
ist herzlich willkommen bei uns,
ob sie nun hierbleiben
oder eine eigene Wohnung suchen.
Il y a aucun probleme, vraiment.
(Eigentlich hätten David und Thomas
vor drei Jahren
im kleinen Rahmen heiraten wollen.)
(Aber Davids Familie
hatte andere Pläne
und es wurde
ein richtig grosses Fest daraus.)
Als die Zeremonie begann und wir
mit der ganzen Familie reinkamen,
hätte ich mich am liebsten
in Luft aufgelöst.
Mein Mund war so trocken,
meine Lippen klebten an den Zähnen.
(So schnell geheiratet
hätten sie auch,
weil es das Zusammenleben als
binationales Paar einfacher macht.)
(Dazu sind in Kanada Hochzeiten
gleichgeschlechtlicher Paare
inzwischen selbstverständlich.)
Das sind sehr schöne Erinnerungen.
* Liebliche Gitarrenklänge *
Was mich bei der Hochzeit
extrem beeindruckt hat ...
Man muss sich das mal vorstellen:
Der Altersunterschied,
ein Ausländer -
wie viele Vorurteile
könnten da vorhanden sein?
Und ich habe nichts davon gespürt
bei der kanadischen Familie.
Sie waren so ... Sie waren so offen.
Und seine Grossmutter
hatte erst kurz davor erfahren,
dass ihr Enkel homosexuell ist und
erst noch einen Schweizer heiratet.
Man muss sich mal vorstellen,
wie die meisten in dem Alter
reagieren würden.
Sie kam auf mich zu - sie hat mich
zum ersten Mal gesehen -,
küsste mich und sagte:
"Du musst ein guter Mann sein, denn
du machst meinen David glücklich."
* Lockere Gitarrenklänge *
(Grenzenlose Liebe heisst:
viel Altes aufgeben
und viel Neues dazugewinnen.)
(Endloses Schneeschaufeln z.B.,
wenn in der Heimat schon langsam
die ersten Schneeglöckchen
erscheinen.)
* Herzschläge *
Es ist ein Unterschied,
ob man frisch verliebt ist
oder ob man verliebt ist
in eine Person.
Es ist ganz klar und das wissen wir,
dass v.a. Chemie dahintersteckt,
wenn man verliebt ist.
Meiner Ansicht nach ist es
relativ logisch, dass es abflaut,
dass die Romantik vom Anfang
langsam ein wenig ...
... etwas verloren geht.
Ja. - Und ...
- Es ist nachher einfach Liebe,
aber natürlich nicht mehr
das Frischverliebte.
Romantik, Romantik,
aber ohne Blumen.
Hast du Blumen für mich geschickt?
Keine Ahnung.
- Das meine ich.
Ich bin nicht der Meinung, dass
sich eine Beziehung bewerten lässt
aufgrund der Menge der Blumen,
die man jemandem schenkt.
* Melancholische Klänge *
(Im Elternhaus von Martin Krättli
in Untervaz.)
Grüezi wohl!
- Hoi, hoi!
Vielen Dank!
- Hallo!
Du bringst auch noch etwas mit?
Grüezi.
(Nur sein jüngerer Bruder Adrian
wusste Bescheid,
als Martin im Oktober 2012
ledig nach Kiew ging
und vier Tage später als Verhei-
rateter zurück in die Schweiz kam.)
(Manchmal sind Tatsachen eben besser
als viele Worte.)
Schon lange nicht mehr, gell?
- Ja, ja.
Wo hast du diese Buchstaben geholt?
Das sind Formen.
Ist es Marzipan?
(Und Adrian wurde von Martin
wohl auch nur deshalb eingeweiht,
weil er ihm den Hochzeitsanzug
ausleihen musste.)
(Er habe jedenfalls
nicht viele Fragen gestellt.)
Schlussendlich
ist es die Sache jedes einzelnen,
wo er eine Frau oder Freundin
kennenlernt.
Schlussendlich ...
... äh, ja ...
war ich sicher überrascht,
dass er jemanden aus Russland
kennengelernt hat,
oder aus der Ukraine.
Aber ich kann ja selbst
nichts sagen.
Ich habe auch
eine aus Russland kennengelernt.
Wobei wir uns in Deutschland
kennengelernt haben, in Hamburg.
(Vom ersten Kontakt bis zur Hochzeit
brauchten Martin und Lana
nur gerade 45 Tage.)
(Bündner Rekord.)
Das ist sicher jemand Besonderes.
Es ist schon in Ordnung.
Ich habe da nichts ...
Bisher haben wir es gut miteinander.
Es klappt. Doch, doch.
(Nach der Hochzeit
schickte Martin seinen Eltern
eine SMS und ein Foto seiner Braut.)
Und sonst ist auch Wasser
in Ordnung.
Familienfeste in der Schweiz
sind ganz anders als in Russland
oder der Ukraine.
Dort ist immer Alkohol im Spiel.
Und am Schluss singen
und musizieren und tanzen alle.
(Die kulturellen Unterschiede
seien nicht immer ganz einfach.)
(Und der Alkohol
hat sogar für einen Moment
das junge Eheglück
von Martin und Lana bedroht.)
Ich weiss,
dass ich eine Minderheit bin.
Aber ich bin auch der Meinung,
dass diese Minderheitsmeinung
die richtige Meinung ist.
Richtige Meinung, ja.
In diesem Fall wiederhole ich, dass
mein Ehemann perfekt für mich ist.
Darum dieser Mann
und kein ukrainischer.
Denn er kann nicht ...
Er trinkt keinen Alkohol.
- Ich mag ihn nicht.
Ja. Das ist für meinen Charakter,
mein Temperament besser.
Wenn wir schauen, wie viel ...
Sie wurde auch
von ehemaligen Freunden geschlagen,
als sie betrunken waren.
Oder wie oft erlebt man Gewalt in
Familien, weil jemand betrunken ist?
Ich habe schon oft erlebt,
wie Menschen, die trinken,
sich total verändern.
Und das finde ich schade.
*  Herzschläge *
(Bald nach der Hochzeit
kam Lana in die Schweiz.)
(Als ihr Sohn Leon zur Welt kommt,
scheint das Glück perfekt.)
(Aber in Lanas Innern
sah es zu dieser Zeit anders aus.)
(So weit weg von zu Hause,
ohne Umfeld, ohne Freunde,
und vom Schweizerdeutschen
verstand sie auch nichts.)
Ich war immer allein.
Mir wurde das im Moment
einfach zu viel.
Ich hätte mir gewünscht,
dass Martin mich einfach mal
in den Arm genommen hätte.
Natürlich habe ich ihn unter Druck
gesetzt, habe ausgerufen.
Ich habe gesagt,
ich könne so nicht weiterleben.
Ich wollte, das er mich beruhigt
und sein Mitleid zeigt.
Stattdessen sagte er nur:
"Ja, und jetzt?
Sollen wir uns scheiden lassen?"
Und ich sagte:
"Ja! Komm, lass uns scheiden!"
Er musste sich setzen.
Aber ich war ja angetrunken
und meinte das nicht ernst.
Für mich war das nur Theater.
Sie hat es ganz gut beschrieben.
Ich weiss noch,
dass damals für mich ...
Ich hatte wirklich das Gefühl,
sie wolle sich scheiden lassen.
Sie sei nicht mehr zufrieden
mit dem, was wir sind.
Klar, ich hatte Angst, dass sie
dann zurück in die Ukraine müsste.
Und dass sie darum kämpfen würde,
dass Leon ... - No, no, no!
Ja, ja, aber das waren meine Ängste.
Ich war natürlich verzweifelt.
Vielleicht haben wir
diese Situation gebraucht,
um zu verst...
* Herzschläge *
Wie sieht es aus mit grauen Haaren?
Mehr und mehr, jedes Mal im Plus.
Okay.
- Aber das ist sexy.
Also, der George-Clooney-Effekt.
- Ja, ja.
Super, Mama!
- 10 Fr.!
Perfect!
Ja, cool!
Sehr gut.
Danke!
* Einzelne Akkordeonklänge *
Ich hatte nie das Gefühl,
etwas aufgegeben zu haben,
das ist das Schöne an dieser Liebe.
Denn wenn du das Gefühl hast,
etwas aufgeben zu müssen,
bist du nicht auf dem richtigen Weg.
Das macht man automatisch.
Für die Liebe macht man das automa-
tisch, es kostet keine Überwindung.
Ich vermisse mein altes Leben nicht.
Mir scheint unser heutiges Leben
sehr schön.
Auch wenn mein Bruder
von uns gegangen ist,
was sehr schwierig war. Mein Bruder
war 19 Jahre lang mit mir.
Ich bin dankbar dafür
und konnte ihn gehen lassen.
Jetzt leben wir
einen neuen Abschnitt.
Demis ist Teil
unseres Lebens geworden
und wir sind jetzt sehr glücklich.
* Fröhliche mexikanische Musik *
(Nancy und Demis führen
ein Künstler- und Vagabundenleben.)
(Sie malt Bilder
und verkauft diese auch,
und er produziert Filme
fürs Internet.)
(Eigentlich ist das ganze Leben der
beiden ein kleines Gesamtkunstwerk.)
(Weltenbummler, Erntehelfer,
Influencer und Gelegenheitsarbeiter -
Hauptsache, sie sind zusammen.)
(Für ihre YouTube-Fangemeinde
drehen sie heute ein neues Video
ausserhalb von Monterrey.)
Fährst immer du, Nancy,
oder fährt er auch hier in Mexiko?
Doch, doch, er fährt auch.
Lüg nicht, meine Liebe!
Du lässt mich nie fahren.
Und Mutter auch nicht.
- Warum nicht?
Ihre Mutter lässt mich nie fahren,
weil ich den Blinker setze
und so korrekt bin. - Was?
Ich schalte den Blinker ein,
wenn ich die Spur wechsle.
Das muss man doch.
Ja, ich halte mich an die Regeln.
Und das ist falsch.
Wechsle ich die Spur
und setze den Blinker,
wollen in Mexiko
noch alle schnell vorbeifahren,
weil sie den Blinker sehen.
Sie sagt, man muss einfach
die Spur wechseln, ruck, zuck,
dann halten sie schon an.
Eigentlich sagt sie,
du bist zu sehr Schweizer,
um in Mexiko
sicher Auto fahren zu können.
Es gibt zu viele Regeln,
die ich nicht kenne.
* Energiegeladene
mexikanische Musik *
Eine wahnsinnige Kulisse!
(Nancy und Demis
sind in Mexiko Online-Stars.)
(Dank ihrer Videos
in den sozialen Medien
kennt das halbe Land die Geschichte
des schrägen Schweizers,
der sich erst in eine Mexikanerin
und dann ins Land verliebt hat.)
Hola!
Grabando esta belleza de Monterrey.
La Huasteca.
(Die Arbeit als YouTuber
hat eher zufällig begonnen.)
(Mit selbst gemachten Videos
wollten sie ihren Freunden
und Familien zu Hause zeigen,
wo sie gerade herumreisen.)
Oh, wow, so beautiful!
(Jetzt folgen ihnen auf YouTube,
Facebook und Instagram
über 100'000 Leute.)
* Demis spricht spanisch. *
* Sie machen wortlose Laute. *
* Nancy spricht spanisch. *
Es ist super,
wenn mal jemand meinen Job macht
und ich einfach zuschauen kann.
Manchmal sagen wir das Gleiche,
zuerst sie, dann ich.
Dann kann ich schneiden.
Hey, I'm Demis.
- Y yo soy Nancy.
We are ...
- Somos ...
(Beide) Vagaboom!
* Liebliche Gitarrenmusik,
Herzschläge *
Sie sagte: "Nimm meine Hand
und bring mich, wohin du willst."
"Ich weiss nicht, was ich will."
Wir sind mit dem Fahrrad aus der
Kirche, sind nach Alaska geflogen.
Nancy merkte: "Hier sind keine
Touristen. Wo bringst du mich hin?"
Ich antwortete: "Du sagtest,
du gehst überall mit mir hin."
"Also kommst du nach Alaska."
Ich war damals so traurig,
dass ich sterben wollte.
So sagte ich mir:
"Wenn mir mein Leben egal ist
und du mit dem Rad losziehen willst,
dann komme ich mit."
"Egal, was passiert -
machen wir es!"
(Ihr Ziel: von Alaska
bis nach Patagonien zu fahren.)
(Tausende von Kilometern,
und alles mit dem Fahrrad.)
(Ein gemeinsames grosses Abenteuer
und ein Weg,
um die Trauer zu verarbeiten
und nach dem Tod des Bruders
neuen Sinn im Leben zu finden.)
Von Gefahr zu Gefahr hat sie
ihre Lebenslust wieder entdeckt.
"Hey, ich will morgen
auch noch leben! Das ist super."
(Wenn ihnen unterwegs
das Geld ausging,
arbeiteten sie auf kalifornischen
Obstplantagen als Hilfsarbeiter.)
Im Süden Mexikos stellten wir
die Fahrräder ab und sie sagte:
"Stopp! Stopp!
"Es sind zwei Jahre vergangen,
immer auf dem Fahrrad."
Ich fand: "Okay. Du wusstest nie,
was du willst. Was willst du jetzt?"
"Ich will das, das, das, ... Ich
will malen und dieses und jenes."
"Okay, das Fahrrad
ist keine Priorität."
"Schauen wir,
dass du dich erfüllen kannst."
Sie kam entschlossen
nach Monterrey zurück,
sie begann, wie wild zu malen,
denn sie wusste,
wenn sie nicht malt,
sitzen wir wieder auf dem Rad.
So hat sie es geschafft, sich mit
ihrer Kunst einen Namen zu machen.
Ich kann überall Videos machen.
Ich habe mich ihr angepasst.
Nach dieser Abenteuerreise wurden
die Videos einfach schlichter:
mein Leben in Mexiko.
Und diese Videos liefen dann besser
als unsere Abenteuervideos
von Alaska bis nach Mexiko.
(Heute strotzen die beiden
vor Lebensfreude und neuem Mut.)
(Wobei der Übermut
eher Demis' Domäne ist.)
Was würdest du nicht für ihn tun,
weil es zu gefährlich ist?
Ich tu das auch für mich, aber Demis
riskiert manchmal etwas viel.
Hast du gehört? Du bist der Spinner
in der Beziehung. Stimmt das?
Ja, ich bin mehr der Abenteurer.
Sie ist die Vernünftigere.
Und wann passt du dich an?
Ich war ziemlich eigensinnig
und ich wollte nie teilen.
Was mir gehörte, war meins,
und ich teilte mit niemandem.
Sie empfängt alle mit offenen Armen:
"Mi casa es tu casa."
Das konnte ich nicht verstehen,
und ich musste mich anpassen.
Als wir mit dem Fahrrad unterwegs
waren, wurde uns überall geholfen.
Immer haben alle
alles mit uns geteilt.
Wieso sollen wir nicht auch teilen?
Hier musste sich der Schweizer
also dem Mexikaner anpassen.
Ja, wenn ich mich
nicht angepasst hätte,
wären wir heute nicht zusammen.
Das Teilen
ist für Mexikaner sehr wichtig.
Das wäre ein Trennungsgrund?
- Das wäre ein Grund gewesen.
* Sie sprechen spanisch. *
Hier braucht man
kein Fitnesscenter mehr,
aber ganz Suva-konform ist es nicht.
(Die Grosszügigkeit der Mexikaner
lerne ich nächste Woche kennen.)
(Familie Cortez
verteilt Essen auf der Strasse.)
Es hat, solange es hat.
(Lana aus Thusis bekommt Besuch.)
(Ihre Mutter
reist aus der Ukraine an.)
Sie plant, drei Monate zu bleiben.
Und ...
Es wird sich zeigen, ob das geht.
(Brigitte bereitet sich auf ein
wichtiges indianisches Ritual vor.)
Am Anfang war ich so richtig
schweizerisch vom Charakter her.
(Hin und weg.)
# Forever you and me.